At age two, doctors told Genie's parents that she had mild retardation. Now her
father, who was not mentally stable, thought that this meant that she was
severely retarded and that she needed protection. Now what happens next is
quite tragic. Throughout her life during the day, her father tied her to a
chair, and in the evenings he caged her in a crib. Moreover, whenever Genie
tried to speak, her father beat her and barked at her like a dog. Now this
happened to her throughout her life until she was about thirteen years old when
her mother ran away and took Genie with her. Now when the social worker first
met Genie, she though she was only six or seven years old. And this is because
Genie was only four foot six inches tall and fifty nine pounds. Not what you
would expect from a typically developing thirteen and a half year old. In
addition Genie had very limited language abilities. She could only say things
such as no more or stop it. Intestingly, after four years of lanuages training,
Genie still had limited language abilities. She could meet simple demands in
terms of speaking simple sentences but she could not speak grammatically.
Interestingly though, her language comprehension was much better than her
language production. Meaning that she was able to understand much of what
people said to her. [BLANK_AUDIO]